now Arab leaders have condemned a visit
by Israel's new far-right security
minister to one of Jerusalem's most
hotly contested holy sites Palestinians
are angry that a security detail
accompanied itema Ben gavier into the
compound he insists Jews must be able to
visit Temple Mount which is known to
Palestinians as the noble sanctuary
born in as Israel's national security
minister
far-right politician etamir bengaver has
visited the site the Temple Mount is the
most important place to the people of
Israel the Temple Mount is open for
everybody Muslim visitors are coming
Christians and yes Jews too in a
government I'm a member of there won't
be racism and discrimination and Jews
will go to the Temple Mount we clarify
this for Hamas we do not surrender we do
not bow he toured the grounds flanked by
armed security a move that has outraged
Palestinians the militant Islamic group
Hamas recognized as a terrorist
organization by the EU has threatened
repercussions
increases the state of tension
brings matters closer to a major
explosion
and it opens the door white for a real
escalation
Arrangement non-muslims are allowed to
visit the holy Compound on the condition
they do not pray but the visit of an
ultra nationalist Israeli minister is a
sensitive matter
the security forces think this is a
dangerous move it is not an accident
that ministers have avoided visiting for
many years it will be seen by the whole
world as breaking the status quo even if
it's not it is an unnecessary risk
the complex is the most sacred side to
Jews and the third holiest place for
Muslims competing claims over the shrine
represent a major source of conflict
between the two sides
one that has often resulted in violence
oh earlier I asked our correspondent
Rebecca Ritter's in Jerusalem why this
visit has drawn so much condemnation
benvir is as you mentioned a very new
member uh of the government he's himself
a settler he's from the very right-wing
extreme parties that make up the faction
that make up the gov the Coalition
rather that make up the government and
that is potentially seen as even more of
a provocation just you know who what he
symbolizes and what he said in the
lead-up to the election all the rhetoric
how about how he wants more access for
Jews how he does want to change the
status quo to allow Jews to be able to
pray up there and so this move today
well it isn't a technical change to the
status quo we've seen as a provocation
that as you rightly point out has been
condemned both inside by the opposition
it's been condemned by the Palestinian
Authority Hamas has come out saying that
this activity any continuation of this
activity would lead to violence it is
being sent as a provocation it's
neighbors as well Israel's neighbors
also very upset by this move the Israeli
ambassador to Jordan was summoned for
addressing down for a talking to if you
will this has been seen very seriously
by Israel and by its neighbors